it's time for our scene and unseen
segment where we explore the cultural
stories of the day and for that we turn
to fox news contributor raymond arroyo
all right raymond the january 6 hearings
were on again today
laura i watched a lot of those hearings
earlier you know they lack drama and the
visuals are not all that appealing so
it's confusing to the viewer the
witnesses were mostly virtual now trump
campaign manager bill stephen looked
like he was photo bombing his lawyer
during a zoom call then poor former
attorney general bill barr showed up he
seemed to be captured on a security cam
at a board meeting and this was the big
revelation of the day brace yourself for
it the committee claimed this was hot
news i told him that the stuff that his
people were shoveling out to the public
were bulk was
i mean that the claims of fraud were
our was just on a book tour laura in
march where he told nbc news this
i told him that
all that all this stuff was [ __ ]
and
about election fraud
and
it was wrong to be shoveling it out the
way his team was
i mean how
where was the new news
i mean
it's all recycled everything the video
is recycled the testimonies recycled and
and bar already did a book on this so i
don't know why these networks are having
panels and live coverage and like
something's new just breaking nothing is
new here this thing all warmed over i
like all the little jump cut edits like
sound bite to sound bite to live person
you don't know it's it's kind of a
russian roulette of sound bites
i didn't find it convincing
the upshot is laura it's hard to win
best revival of an old political story
when your people are suffering from
inflation food prices and rising gas
prices and cbs by the way aired the
prime time hearing the first one last
thursday it drew 3.24 million viewers
now a week before a rerun of young
sheldon in the same time slot drew 3.8
million viewers and your favorite show
was on cbs last night the tony awards
did you watch
no i sadly missed well well you weren't
alone though they were up from an
all-time low last year it was the second
lowest tony awards ever which may have
something to do with the host ariana
debose who apparently never heard the
adage let the audience come to you
[Music]
i am close to you
oh
so close to you
i am
oh my lord i think you just slipped it
you see what you missed yeah he just
slipped a disc in that last
movement there i think he's gonna call
the chiropractor
or whatever no
it was a it was a torturous uh evening i
have to say and remember when broadway
diva patti lupone chastised a member of
her audience a few weeks back
put your mouth over your nose that's why
you're in the theater that is the rule
if you don't want to follow the rule
well last night patti lupone was there
masculist in a crowd
thousands in the orchestra of radio city
musical there she was but don't worry
the workers in the mezzanine of radio
city had to wear their masks laura you
see apparently covid sticks to the
lighting grid at radio city so i guess
it's okay for the people the fancy folks
on the floor no masks for them pretty
good
i can't believe raymond that um
that tony didn't go to phantom of the
covid because that mask was so um
it was so important so impressive and
that i mean that's all that's crazy but
but it's it's it's so hypocritical there
is a masked mandate on broadway right
now through june 30th the audience has
to wear a mask why don't they have to
wear it bad examples here
oh what else
well you you were flipping you were
telling me you were flipping around the
other night oh yeah and and across the
yeah and this
i saw this rupaul show and i have to say
that the makeup on some of the drag
performers i thought was actually pretty
convincing
and it's so convincing they're now even
impersonating political figures raymond
please give a warm drag race welcome to
the speaker of the house nancy pelosi
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
no no that looks like that was actually
pelosi herself that is pelosi yeah
because if you're trying to reach voters
laura before the midterms where else
would you go but rupaul's drag race
now speaker pelosi with all the
challenges facing our nation what words
of wisdom do you have for us well the
single most important thing i can say is
to vote with the midterm elections
coming up it's very important for people
to make their voices and their vote
heard we throw the word master class
around here all the time but that
sarcastic shady clap you do was
epic it was completely unintentional can
i get a an amen
i think they should have done this
raymond remember when after trump did
the state of the union
and she did this
remember that that was her well that's
what they were classic move yeah yeah
well you know this this may be a backup
career for nancy pelosi a judge on
rupaul's drag race and you know she'll
hang up the gavel but this is the future
and look she does know her running way
around the paints and throwing shades so
she's weird i can't i don't that wasn't
pelosi all right thank you raymond hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else